hey I'm right in the middle of giving a
swim lesson oh sorry
what are you wearing oh it's my um my
uniform from the CHP are you supposed to
change out of it after you get off work
yeah you can I mean probably most guys
you know it's my first day so I thought
you'd probably wanna see what I look
like in all Brown great done [ __ ]
only instead of us we get to the
hospital we do all the questioning okay
yeah yeah okay
come now just you and your Park was that
you sexting with Karen no une she's
handcuffed to a pole she's been held
Hospital oh my god oh my god
okay he dropped a pin that's where she's
out that's across the street from the
devil punch wall we gotta take the bike
no wait wait well let's just think about
this why are we gonna risk our life to
say your dirtbag ex wife she's fill your
house you kicked my weak-kneed said my
wife was someone else and I still saved
your life you saved someone when you can
Pont that's what a person does
especially an officer of the law just to
feel you can't even write listen I've
done backflips with worse injuries in it
we're gonna need backup
we don't know who in this department is
in on it I trust you you trust me okay
we're like jay-z and Beyonce with
ride-or-die [ __ ] only in cinemas play
your back already - that's great you
[ __ ] oh that's a weird way to thank
me for saving your life buddy but you're
welcome shooting me was an act of
kindness nobody sees what's wrong with
you you gotta stop shooting Alex that
was my bad California Highway Patrol
that's why I fell from that armored car
job you think some of their own were
involved I want you to go on the inside
going to cover within the Department of
awesome you're gonna be with a rookie
named John Baker you're gonna be francis
llewellyn poncherello fucked-up name are
the first two female names John none of
these scores meet even the lowest
standard you've had 23 surgeries I feel
pretty darn good I'm on a pharmaceutical
regiment that helps a lot more than that
you can lie motorcycle
yes ma'am like a [ __ ] I like you
thank you yeah my thighs thank you
look up I'm John hot roller awesome man
we're partners pretty badass
you speed it up for battle looking like
UPS driver yeah that's super cool
this job is crucial for saving my
marriage what are you wearing my uniform
I thought you've I wanna see what I look
like you know Brown great done it's like
you're three beers too intimate almost
elf motorcycle cop I got no emotion this
job find a 5:30 calm Michael never catch
those great things on the boy and I got
stopped are you guys talking [ __ ] I mean
think you said they like to bike to see
you is pointing at my dick I feel like I
heard poppy no I think it's small it
said a little soap Austin you make the
bike so tiny
oh you have to take off I hope that
you're not preying on girls with low
self-esteem like like her hair like hell
straight their teeth are yeah really
shallow real talk
she paid my punch she ate your ass
everyone's eating everyone's ass now
what about hygiene if you go to the
bathroom in use baby wipes Queen like 24
hours to solve this case for you fine
there's always track this guy why don't
you can of space we don't have a [ __ ]
bat computer right Google
you've been carrying me over that bath
I'll drag you there but I'm not gonna
cradle you like a new blind save your
life I knew you were gonna bring that up
just get it over with
ah these bass playing into my pubic
mom's no no no that could have swore I
felt you know your nose or your lips you
might be like a little bit of contact
when you get intimate with you gals is
oral expected like I ain't as with the
bus oh yeah a standard book at standard
Wow things have changed
[Music]
you